what would you say motivates you in this
now and in the years leading up to now
the love of winning or the fear of
losing
so for
the world championship it's been fair of
losing for sure
other tournaments
love of winning is
a great great factor
and that's why i also get more joy from
from winning most tournaments than i do
for winning the world championship
because then it's mostly been a
a relief i also think i enjoy winning
more now than i did
before because
i feel like i'm a little bit more
relaxed now and um i also know that it's
you know it's not gonna last forever so
every every little win i
i appreciate um appreciate a lot more
now and and yeah in terms of fear for
losing like that's a huge reason why i'm
not going to play the world championship
because
uh i it really didn't give me give me a
lot of joy it really was all about
avoiding losing
why is it that the world championship
really makes you feel this way the
anxiety so and when you say losing do
you mean
not just a match but like every single
position like
no it's just the fear of a blunder
no i mean the blunder is okay like when
i sit down at the board then it's it's
mostly been fine because then i then i'm
focused on got it then i'm focused on
the game and i know i know that i can
play the game it's a time like in
between like knowing that you know
i feel like losing is not an option
because it's the world championship and
because in a world championship there
are two players there's there's a winner
and a loser if i don't win a random
tournament that i play
then you know i'm usually
it depends on the tournament i might be
disappointed for sure
might even be pretty pissed but
ultimately you know you go on to the
next one with the world championship you
don't go on to the next one it's like
it's years
yeah and
it also has been like it's been a core
part of my identity for a while now that
i am world champion
and so
there's not an option of
of losing that yeah
yeah there's uh you're gonna have to at
least for a couple of years carry the
the weight of having lost
you're
the former world champion now if you
lose
versus the current world champion
there are certain sports that
create that anxiety and others that
don't for example i think ufc like mixed
martial arts are a little better with
losing
it's understood like everybody loses
uh but there's not everybody though not
everybody not everybody not everybody
yes
could be bent to the chat uh
but in boxing there is like that extra
pressure of like maintaining the
championship
i mean maybe you could say the same
thing about the the ufc as well so for
you personally for a person
who loves chess
the first time you won the world
championship that was that was the big
that was the thing that was fun
yeah and then everything after
is like stressful yeah
uh essentially there was certainly
stress uh involved the first time as
well um
but
it was nothing compared to uh
compared to the others
so the only world championship after
that that i really enjoyed was the one
in 2018 against the american fabiano
corona and what that made that different
is
that i'd been kind of slumping for a bit
and he'd been on the rise so our ratings
were very very similar
they were so close that if at any point
during the
during the match i'd lost the game
he would have been ranked as number one
in the world like our ratings were so
close that for each draw they didn't
move
and and the game itself was close yeah
the games themselves were very close uh
i
i had a winning position in in the first
game that i couldn't really get anywhere
for a lot of games then he had a couple
of games where he could potentially have
won
then in the last game i was a little bit
better and eventually they were all they
were all drawn but i felt like all the
way that this is an interesting match
against an an opponent who is at this
position
at this point equal to me
and so losing that would not have been
this disaster
because all in all the other matches i
would know that i would i've lost
against somebody
who i know
i'm much better than and that would be
would be a lot harder for me to um to
take well that's fascinating and
beautiful that the stress isn't from
losing this
because you have fun
you enjoy playing against somebody who's
as good as you maybe better than you
that's exciting to you yeah uh it's it's
it's losing at this high stakes thing
that only happens
rarely
to a person who's not as good as you
yeah and that's why it's also been
incredibly frustrating in other matches
like when i know
when we play draw after draw
and i can just i i know that i'm better
i can
sense during the game that i understand
better than them but i cannot you know i
cannot get over the hump
you